il y à un passager à bord de ce vol qui
a menacé de tuer kaka toutes les 20
minutes
à moins qu'on lui en mettre 150 millions
$
trois personnes sont déjà mortes et la
bombe va exploser dans moins d'une demi
heure
on veut que vous pensiez que c'est moi
le responsable tout ce que vous avez
entendu ce mois est vrai j'ai perdu ma
famille mon boulot et je suis alcoolique
ma fille à l'âge de 5 ans a développé
une leucémie aiguë j'ai passé mes
journées à travailler au lieu de rester
auprès d'elle pour m'en occuper parce
que j'avais la trouille de la voir
mourir je ne suis pas un bon père
je ne suis pas un type bien
je n'essaie pas de détourner cet avion
j'essaie de le sauver